Alors je vais une introduction parce que je pense que la dernière fois que nous avons eu à aborder le passage de la prédication autour d'Ézéchiel, c'était en décembre dernier, fin décembre.
Et donc je vais donner un petit rappel, un petit résumé aussi pour nous permettre d'entrer, de mieux rentrer dans le contexte.
Donc dans le chapitre 6, déjà le contexte c'est Ézéchiel qui était un juif qui a été déporté avec un certain nombre de son peuple.
Ils ont été déportés à Babylone lorsque le roi Nebuchadnezzar avait attaqué Jérusalem.
Donc il est rentré une fois dans Jérusalem, il a pris l'élite du peuple, donc Ézéchiel faisait partie de l'élite puisque Ézéchiel était un sacrificateur.
Et Daniel faisait partie de la cour royale et donc il a pris toutes ces personnes, les emmena à Babylone.
Et à Babylone, là où Ézéchiel pensait qu'il avait perdu Dieu, que Dieu était absent, Dieu s'est révélé à Ézéchiel dans Babylone.
Et Dieu se révèle à Ézéchiel et il lui révèle pourquoi toutes ces choses leur arrivent.
Il leur révèle que c'est parce qu'après plusieurs siècles de patience, Dieu est en train de juger Israël.
Et il décide de dire à un moment à Ézéchiel, toi tu vas porter ce message.
Bien sûr avec beaucoup de difficultés, ils ne vont pas t'écouter, ils refuseront même d'accepter que c'est à cause de cela.
Mais c'est ce que tu dois leur dire.
Donc dans le chapitre précédent, au chapitre 6, nous avions vu que Dieu annonçait la cause, que la cause de la destruction de Jérusalem n'était pas la bravo de Nebuchadnezzar.
La cause de la destruction de Jérusalem, ce n'était pas parce qu'il y avait eu un royaume tellement puissant que maintenant Israël ne pouvait pas résister.
Non, la cause était spirituelle.
C'est très important à considérer.
Les hommes voyaient ce qu'ils voyaient, mais la cause était spirituelle.
C'est parce qu'Israël, à cause de son idolâtrie, à cause du rejet de Dieu, à cause du culte des idoles, des idoles qu'ils avaient fait de main d'homme, Dieu était en train de détruire Jérusalem.
Dieu allait non seulement détruire Jérusalem, mais il allait aussi détruire toutes les idoles avec eux.
Et c'était aussi un signe fort.
Mais Dieu promettait que malgré le jugement qu'il manifestait sur Jérusalem, il allait quand même se réserver un reste qu'il allait épargner, un reste qui allait passer par la repentance.
C'est-à-dire que c'est un reste qui allait comprendre ce qui s'était passé réellement selon le plan de Dieu.
Et c'est un reste qui allait se repentir et qui allait revenir plus tard à Dieu et plus tard à Jérusalem.
Donc à la fin du chapitre 6, Dieu instruit Ézéchiel, et même quand nous lisons d'autres passages, Ésaïe et d'autres prophètes,
il les instruit à déplorer les iniquités d'Israël, il les instruit à pleurer sur les iniquités d'Israël.
Donc nous voyons déjà que c'est quelque chose que Dieu n'était pas en train de faire parce qu'il était un Dieu impitoyable sans amour.
Non, au contraire, le jugement d'Israël était un signe de l'amour de Dieu.
C'était un signe de la compassion de Dieu.
Et voilà pourquoi à un moment, il a levé les prophètes pour pouvoir pleurer sur Jérusalem.
Voilà pourquoi Jérémie pleure sur Jérusalem, l'amantation de Jérémie.
Voilà pourquoi Ézéchiel pleure, Ésaïe va pleurer, tous les prophètes vont pleurer sur Jérusalem parce que Dieu avait de la compassion.
Dans le nouveau chapitre, ce que nous avons abordé dans ce chapitre 7, nous voyons que bien qu'Ézéchiel soit en train de pleurer,
donc il soit en train de pleurer dans ce chapitre, Dieu lui indique un moment, et c'est ce que nous avions vu en décembre dernier,
il indique un moment que par cette destruction, Dieu était en train de mettre fin à la vie mésirable d'Israël.
C'est-à-dire qu'Israël, juste avant la chute, pouvait se considérer prospère, il pouvait se considérer comme étant béni même par Dieu,
mais pour Dieu, quel que soit ce que nous pouvons être, quel que soit ce que nous pouvons faire,
du moment où notre vie est caractérisée par l'idolâtrie, nous avons une vie misérable.
Israël était misérable, quel que soit ce qu'il pouvait penser.
Et donc Dieu, et c'est ce que nous avons vu dernièrement dans les versets 1 à 6, nous avons vu à un moment que Dieu décide de détruire Israël
à cause de cette vie misérable qui était caractérisée par l'idolâtrie.
Et aujourd'hui, nous allons aborder en introduction cette partie des versets 7 à 10, qui parle d'une ruine qui sera imminente.
Même si eux, ils ne voyaient pas les signes de cette destruction, parce qu'ils étaient dans une situation où ils avaient réussi à se...
Donc cette situation, quand nous parlons, c'est qu'à un moment, ils ont réussi à se détacher de l'emprise de Nébuchadnezzar.
L'Égypte est venue les aider.
Nébuchadnezzar a dû se retirer de Jérusalem.
Et là, ils sont sûrs qu'ils sont sauvés.
Mais Dieu leur dit, même si vous ne voulez pas voir les signes, même si vous pensez que vous êtes sauvés, la destruction est imminente.
Donc aujourd'hui, nous allons aborder le début des versets 7 à 10.
Nous allons nous concentrer essentiellement sur les versets 5 à 7.
Et dans ces versets, ils nous annoncent non seulement que cette ruine était certaine, mais qu'elle était aussi imminente.
Et qu'est-ce que ça voulait dire par là ?
C'est que la patience de Dieu était épuisée.
Qu'est-ce que la parole peut nous enseigner au travers du fait de parler de la patience de Dieu qui était épuisée ?
Le premier point, nous allons...
Je vais un peu résumer, parce que pour comprendre, pour bien aborder le verset 7,
qui sera un peu au cœur du message aujourd'hui,
c'est bien de revenir sur ce que nous avons dit, un rappel sur les versets 1 à 6.
Donc, ce que nous avons dit sur les versets 1 à 6 dernièrement,
nous voyons à un moment que ce que Dieu est en train de dire,
c'est que la fin vers laquelle ont tendu tous les jugements,
c'est-à-dire que depuis Moïse, qui établit la nation d'Israël,
et qui leur donne les dix commandements,
Moïse les met en garde contre l'idolâtrie.
Il leur dit à un moment, si vous choisissez la voie de l'Éternel, il vous bénira.
Mais si vous allez dans l'idolâtrie, vous serez détruits.
Et donc, depuis Moïse, il y avait une annonce assez claire.
Et déjà, au temps de Moïse, Israël va être puni plusieurs fois par Dieu,
parce qu'à un moment, ils se sont détournés de Dieu pour aller vers des idoles.
Et Dieu les juge.
C'était des jugements temporaires.
Et donc, depuis Moïse jusqu'à Ézéchiel, jusqu'à Jérémie,
nous voyons à un moment que tous les jugements qui se sont passés tout au long de l'histoire
étaient des jugements où Dieu exerçait sa patience.
Il n'avait pas détruit totalement Israël.
C'était le cycle.
Israël se détourne de Dieu.
Dieu les laisse à la merci des nations qui sont autour d'eux.
Israël réalise qu'ils ont péché.
Ils se repentent.
Dieu leur envoie un libérateur.
Ils sont libérés de cette nation.
Ils restent dans le droit chemin.
Quelques temps plus tard, Israël, dès que celui qui...
le conducteur qui craignait Dieu meurt,
Israël se détourne.
Israël repart dans l'idolâtrie.
Donc, c'était ce cycle pendant plusieurs siècles.
Mais maintenant, Dieu est en train de dire qu'il n'y aura plus ce cycle.
Ce cycle ne va plus avoir lieu.
Maintenant, ce sera une ruine complète.
Ils ne seront pas épargnés comme ils ont pu l'être lors des siècles précédents.
Et Dieu, pour bien parler, quand on parle du jugement,
quand on parle du jugement que nous avons lu dans les versets 1 à 10,
on parle d'un jugement qui est semblable au déluge.
On parle d'un jugement qui est semblable au jugement qui a été exercé sur Sodome et Gomorre.
C'est une destruction totale.
C'est un jugement qui est en train d'arriver malgré les doutes d'Israël.
Et c'est ça qui était...
Parce qu'Israël regardait à ce qui était autour d'eux.
Ils avaient déjà eu un avertissement.
Lorsqu'ils ont été...
Lorsque Ézéchiel, Daniel ont été déportés,
mais ils ont refusé de se repentir.
Et lorsque Nebuchadnezzar a été distrait par le pharaon d'Égypte,
qu'il va même vaincre.
Parce que ce qui va se passer, c'est...
Après, quand il va vaincre le pharaon d'Égypte,
il va revenir à Jérusalem.
Et donc, eux qui...
Et voilà pourquoi Jérémie parle à un moment de l'Égypte qui a un roseau cassé.
Parce qu'à un moment, ils mettaient leur espoir
que le pharaon d'Égypte puisse vaincre Nebuchadnezzar.
Et là, ils étaient délivrés.
Mais dès que Nebuchadnezzar va vaincre le pharaon d'Égypte,
Israël sait que Nebuchadnezzar revient à Jérusalem.
Et même malgré ça, ils ne veulent pas se repentir.
Mais qu'est-ce que Dieu nous enseigne pour nous qui sommes arrivés à la fin des temps,
au travers de cet exemple,
c'est que nous aussi, nous devons prendre conscience
comme il y a eu le jugement de Dieu dans le jardin d'Éden,
comme il y a eu le jugement de Dieu au travers du déluge,
comme il y a eu le jugement de Dieu sur Sodome et Gomorre,
même après des siècles de patience,
depuis Adam jusqu'à nos temps,
Dieu jugera la méchanceté de ce monde.
Il ne s'agit pas de jugement temporel que nous pouvons constater,
mais bien d'un jugement définitif
et intemporel.
Et c'est intéressant parce que,
en préparant la prédication,
je réalisais que c'est un message qui nous parle beaucoup,
qui fait beaucoup écho aux situations que nous sommes en train de vivre.
Entre-temps, il y a eu,
alors je ne sais pas,
là on va faire un peu comme le débat chocolatine et autres,
mais moi je dis Epstein,
il y a d'autres qui vont dire Epstein,
je ne sais pas,
mais en tout cas je dis Epstein.
on a eu ce scandale qui était choquant,
qui révélait combien ce monde,
même si on pouvait déjà le deviner,
mais combien ce monde est pourri.
Et là nous sommes dans des situations
où tous ces leaders qui nous obligent souvent à certaines choses
sont en train de se livrer peut-être à une troisième guerre mondiale,
on va dire,
parce que ça peut s'embraser du jour au lendemain.
Et nous voyons un moment que nous vivons dans un monde
où la méchanceté reine.
Et même pour nous qui sommes épargnés
par ce qui peut se passer en Iran
ou d'autres choses,
nous ne sommes pas épargnés de prendre un coup de couteau,
nous ne sommes pas épargnés d'avoir une violence,
une agression et beaucoup d'autres choses.
Et nous réalisons que ce monde
est pourri.
Et ce qui est même assez drôle,
c'est que,
et c'est même là où on voit l'absurdité de l'athéisme,
parce que pour un athée qui va dire à un moment
que nous sommes le fruit de cailloux
qui ont explosé dans l'univers,
c'est intéressant comment l'athée espère trouver un monde parfait.
Nous n'avons jamais connu un monde parfait.
Les seuls qui ont connu un monde parfait,
c'était Adam et Ève.
Mais depuis la chute,
l'homme n'a connu qu'un monde détruit.
Et pourquoi nous sommes en train de porter
cette espérance de trouver un monde meilleur ?
C'est parce que Dieu a inscrit en nous
la pensée de l'éternité.
La pensée de Dieu est inscrite dans le cœur de l'homme.
Parce qu'aucun de nous ne peut imaginer
trouver un monde parfait
dans ce que nous sommes en train de vivre.
Mais nous, nous comprenons
pourquoi nous pouvons avoir un monde parfait.
Voilà ce que Pierre est en train de dire aux frères.
Nous avions lu ce passage dernièrement
dans 2 Pierre 3,
versets 1 à 4,
et ensuite versets 8 à 10.
Donc, versets 1 à 4,
vous voyez, ça fait tellement écho même
pour notre vie actuelle.
Voici déjà, bien aimé,
la seconde lettre que je vous écris.
Dans l'une et dans l'autre,
je cherche à éveiller par des avertissements
votre saine intelligence,
afin que vous vous souveniez
des choses annoncées d'avance
par les saints prophètes
et du commandement du Seigneur et Sauveur
enseignés par vos apôtres.
Sachant avant tout
que dans les derniers jours,
il viendra des moqueurs
avec leur raillerie,
marchant selon leur propre convoitise
et disant où est la promesse
de son avènement.
Car depuis que les pères sont morts,
tout demeure comme dès
le commencement de la création.
La patience de Dieu.
Ça, c'est la patience de Dieu.
La patience de Dieu est raillée.
Elle est moquée.
Mais voilà ce que Pierre nous dit ensuite
dans les versets 8 à 10.
Mais il est une chose bien aimée
que vous ne devez pas ignorer.
Nous aussi, nous ne devons pas l'ignorer.
C'est que devant le Seigneur,
un jour est comme mille ans
et mille ans sont comme un jour.
Le Seigneur ne tarde pas
dans l'accomplissement de la promesse
comme quelques-uns le croient.
Mais il use de patience envers vous,
ne voulant pas qu'aucun périsse,
mais voulant que tous
arrivent à la repentance.
Voilà pourquoi il a usé de patience
envers Israël pendant plusieurs siècles.
Le jour du Seigneur
viendra comme un voleur.
En ce jour,
les cieux passeront avec fracas,
les éléments embrasés se dissoudront
et la terre,
avec les œuvres qu'elle renferme,
sera consumée.
Si c'est moi qui vous avais dit ça ce matin,
vous pourriez mettre en doute ma parole.
Mais nous parlons d'un homme
qui a vécu avec le Créateur de l'univers.
Nous parlons avec un homme
qui a vécu avec celui
qui est le maître des temps
et des circonstances.
Et voilà ce qu'il est en train de nous dire.
Pourquoi ?
Et donc pour nous,
c'est une grande espérance,
ça doit être une grande promesse
qui doit nous faire beaucoup de bien
de savoir un jour
que Dieu jugera la méchanceté.
Là, je reviens encore.
Une chose qui était choquante
quand on réalise,
parce que vous voyez,
aujourd'hui,
on est en train d'être presque
dans l'indifférence
par rapport au scandale Epstein,
alors qu'il est quand même assez,
il est très profond,
il est très,
c'est très horrible.
Parce que certainement,
certaines personnes
qui sont liées à ce scandale
finiront leur vie sur terre
sans être jugées,
sans même être inquiétées
par la justice.
Mais qu'est-ce que la Bible nous dit ?
C'est que Dieu jugera la méchanceté.
Que ce soit dans cette vie,
que ce soit pour l'éternité.
Ces hommes ont la conscience
quand une fois,
j'ai vu une interview
où Epstein dit un moment,
on lui demande,
est-ce que vous croyez en Dieu ?
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de Dieu ?
Il dit,
ce charpentier,
il dit,
et en parlant du Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Mais ce charpentier
le jugera.
Un jour,
il aura à rendre compte
devant ce charpentier.
Pourquoi Dieu est en train
de manifester un jugement
aussi fort
envers un peuple
qu'il aimait ?
Parce qu'à un moment,
il va dire,
Israël,
tu es la prunelle de mes yeux.
Mais pourtant,
il est en train de juger Israël.
Car comme nous l'avons dit
la dernière fois,
et je vais reprendre
ce que j'avais dit,
Dieu parle,
en parlant du péché,
Dieu parle d'un mal unique.
Dans son essence,
le péché est un mal unique
qui ne contient aucun bien.
Il n'y a rien de positif
que nous pouvons tirer du péché.
Quelle que soit la coloration,
quelle que soit la légèreté,
quelle que soit l'excuse
qu'on veut lui donner,
le péché reste le péché.
Et qu'est-ce que la Bible nous dit ?
C'est que le salaire du péché,
dans son essence de mal unique,
c'est la mort.
C'est une mort
qui sera spirituelle,
mais c'est aussi une mort
qui peut être physique.
C'est un seul mal,
c'est un mal qui suffit
à détruire des nations entières.
Voilà pourquoi Dieu parlait
d'une vie misérable pour Israël.
Même si Israël était riche,
même si Israël avait le temple,
parce que vous voyez,
avant que ces événements arrivent,
il y avait tous les trésors,
une bonne partie.
Bien sûr, à un moment,
il y avait eu des situations
où certaines parties du trésor
avaient été arrachées.
Mais Israël pouvait toujours
se glorifier de certaines richesses
qu'ils avaient gardées
pendant plusieurs siècles.
Et ils se voyaient bénis.
Mais Dieu était en train de leur dire,
même quand vous voyez
cette apparence de prospérité,
vous êtes misérables.
Ce que nous devons comprendre
et qui est très important,
une leçon,
ça c'est ce qui a été dit
lorsque nous avons abordé
les versets 1 à 6,
nous devons faire attention
parce que le jugement de Dieu
peut endurcir le cœur.
Il y a deux facettes
lorsque le jugement de Dieu arrive.
Le jugement de Dieu
peut endurcir le cœur du pécheur.
Et nous le voyons, par exemple,
lorsque nous lisons
ce qui est arrivé en Égypte
avec les dix plaies.
Malgré les plaies,
Pharaon n'a fait que s'endurcir.
Pharaon qui aurait dû revenir
à de l'humilité,
qui aurait dû s'abaisser
devant la majesté de Dieu,
devant la puissance de Dieu,
Pharaon n'a fait que s'endurcir
devant le péché.
Et c'est pour ça qu'à un moment,
la Bible nous rappelle
que les miracles ne sont pas
une preuve,
une garantie de salut.
Parce que souvent,
on va se dire à un moment,
il faut des miracles
pour que les gens croient.
Non, les gens peuvent voir
des miracles
et poursuivent leur endurcissement.
Des fois,
le jugement de Dieu
peut endurcir
le cœur du pécheur.
Le jugement peut accentuer
la corruption du cœur.
Parce qu'à un moment,
ça va révéler
ce que nous portons
dans notre cœur.
Mais voilà pourquoi,
pour celui qui goûte
à la grâce de Dieu,
le jugement,
lorsqu'il est exercé,
lorsque nous sommes en train
de vivre une situation
où nous voyons
le jugement de Dieu
et nous pouvons voir
l'exemple, par exemple,
d'Ézéchiel.
Ézéchiel est en train,
c'est-à-dire,
même ses frères
qui étaient sauvés
étaient en train
de vivre le jugement.
Daniel a été déporté.
Malgré la crainte
qu'il avait de Dieu,
Daniel a subi
le jugement avec son peuple.
Ézéchiel a subi,
Ézéchiel a été déporté.
Nous devons comprendre
un moment
que Dieu peut permettre
que le chrétien aussi
puisse traverser
ses afflictions.
Mais,
là où le jugement
peut endurcir
le cœur du pécheur,
lorsque le chrétien
est en train
de faire face
à cela,
c'est une occasion
de sanctification.
Le jugement
va être un moyen
de grand bien
pour l'âme
qui est touchée
par la sainteté de Dieu,
par la miséricorde de Dieu.
Les déportés
à Babylone
l'ont été
pour leur bien,
même s'ils ne l'avaient
pas compris.
Et vous voyez,
même plus tard,
que c'est d'ailleurs
du reste
qui avait été envoyé
à Babylone,
que viendra
la restauration spirituelle
et la restauration
matérielle de Jérusalem.
Spirituelle,
parce qu'à un moment,
eux qui ont été déportés,
ils vont comprendre
que c'est le moment
d'intercéder.
Ils vont se souvenir
de ce que Dieu avait dit
au bout des 70 ans.
Je ramènerai mon peuple
et Daniel va commencer
à intercéder.
Donc,
nous voyons un moment
qu'une même affliction
peut être pour nous
un demi-mal
quand nous retenons
les leçons de Dieu
ou une affliction
peut être un mal absolu
selon la manière
de la subir
et la façon
dont nous en tirons
les fruits.
Et voilà encore pourquoi,
comme nous l'avons lu
dans le texte
des offrandes,
nous devons veiller,
nous devons demeurer
fermes.
Nous devons veiller
sur notre cœur
pour que les afflictions
que nous pouvons
être en train de vivre,
les épreuves
que nous pouvons
être en train de vivre
ne soient pas
l'occasion
d'une hostilité
envers Dieu.
Nous devons veiller
sur notre cœur
pour que les afflictions
que nous pouvons vivre
ne soient pas
l'occasion
d'une méchanceté
contre notre prochain
ou à cause
de l'affliction
que nous sommes
en train de vivre,
nous avons même
du mal à bénir
ce que Dieu
est en train de bénir.
Nous avons même
du mal à dire
Amen
à ce que Dieu
est en train de faire
parce que nous avons
eu quelque chose
dans le cœur
contre Dieu,
contre les hommes.
Ça a été le cas
de Caïen
qui,
irrité contre Dieu,
a porté sa colère
et sa jalousie
sur son frère
Abel
et qu'il a tué.
Mais mon encouragement
pour nous,
voici comment
le psaume 51
nous encourage
à faire face
à l'affliction.
Psaume 51
du verset 10
au verset 15
Dieu,
crée en moi
un cœur pur,
renouvelle en moi
un esprit bien disposé.
Ne me rejette pas
loin de ta face,
ne me retire pas
ton esprit saint.
Rends-moi la joie
de ton salut
et qu'un esprit
de bonne volonté
me soutienne.
J'enseignerai
tes voies
à ceux qui les transgressent
et les pécheurs
reviendront à toi.
Dieu,
Dieu de mon salut,
délivre-moi
du sang versé
et ma langue
célébrera
ta miséricorde.
Seigneur,
ouvre mes lèvres
et ma bouche
publiera
ta louange.
Dieu nous encourage
vis-à-vis
de l'affliction
à prier
pour que pendant
que nous sommes
en train de vivre
ces moments difficiles,
Dieu crée en nous
un cœur pur.
Que nous soyons
en train
d'exposer,
que nous laissions
la parole de Dieu
en train d'exposer,
de sortir
tout ce qui n'est pas bon.
Et que Dieu renouvelle
en nous un esprit
bien disposé.
Cette prière
du psaume 51,
Daniel aurait pu la faire.
Daniel qui avait été
déporté à Babylone
aurait pu la faire.
Ézéchiel aurait pu la faire.
En se disant
au moment,
Seigneur,
ne laisse pas mon cœur
être dans une hostilité
vis-à-vis de toi,
mais que je comprenne
ce que tu es en train
de faire dans ma vie.
Et vous voyez,
il y a des passages
où un moment,
ils reprennent en disant
un moment,
il y avait les gardes
à Babylone
qui se moquaient d'eux
en disant un moment,
où est Jérusalem ?
Où est cette ville
qui avait été vaincue ?
Vous qui croyez
que vous n'alliez jamais
être vaincu.
Les gens se moquaient d'eux.
Mais Dieu nous dit
un moment,
face à l'affliction,
veillons sous notre cœur
pour que notre cœur
reste pur.
Veillons pour que
Dieu ne nous rejette pas
loin de sa face
qui ne nous retire pas
son esprit saint.
Veillons pour que
la joie de son salut
soit notre force.
Veillons pour que
nous soyons en train
d'apprendre
ce que Dieu nous enseigne
parce que plus tard,
nous devons être
un objet de bénédiction
pour les autres.
Voilà ce qu'il dit.
J'enseignerai tes voies
à ceux qui les transgressent
et les pécheurs
reviendront à toi.
Dieu me fait traverser
l'affliction
pour que je comprenne
qui il est
et que je puisse
enseigner davantage
à ceux qui ne le connaissent
pas qui il est.
Seigneur,
ouvre mes lèvres
et ma bouche
publiera ta louange.
Aujourd'hui,
c'est une prière
que même des frères
qui sont en train
d'être bombardés
en Iran,
des frères qui sont
en train d'être bombardés
au Liban,
des frères qui sont,
je connais des frères
qui sont à RDC,
qui sont à la frontière,
là où il y a
les rébellions
et toutes ces choses.
C'est une prière
que ces frères peuvent faire
plutôt que d'être
dans l'affliction
ou la colère
vis-à-vis de Dieu,
de comprendre
que Dieu
est en train
de travailler
leur sanctification
pour qu'il puisse
être une bénédiction
pour cette nation,
pour ce monde
qui est perdu.
Notre Dieu,
nous prions,
nous prions
pour chacun de nous,
pour nos cœurs.
Nous te demandons
pardon chaque fois
que nous pouvons
faire face à l'affliction,
à l'épreuve
et que nous sommes
en train de juger
ta façon d'agir,
que nous sommes
en train de développer
une hostilité
dans notre cœur
vis-à-vis de ta parole,
vis-à-vis de toi,
que nous sommes
en train de développer
une jalousie,
une méchanceté
vis-à-vis de notre prochain
parce que nous estimons
devoir être traités
mieux que cela,
nous estimons
être innocents
et devoir être mieux traités.
Seigneur,
pardonne-nous notre folie
et nous prions
au contraire,
Seigneur,
pour que, Seigneur,
tu disposes en nous
un cœur pur,
que tu renouvelles
nos pensées
pour que nous réalisions
que toi,
notre Dieu,
tu es le maître
des temps
et des circonstances
et que quand tu permets
ces choses dans notre vie,
c'est pour que nous puissions
davantage apprendre
qui tu es,
c'est pour que là
où nos oreilles
avaient entendu
parler de cet aspect
de toi,
nos yeux puissent
voir ta miséricorde,
puissent voir ton amour.
Seigneur,
nous prions
pour nos cœurs
afin que notre bouche
puisse publier
ta louange
au milieu
de l'assemblée
et vis-à-vis
de ceux
qui ne te connaissent pas.
Nous prions
en nom de Saint Jésus-Christ.
Amen.
Mais la parole de Dieu
nous dit un moment,
mais lorsque la fin
arrive pour les méchants,
comme il est indiqué
au verset 6,
« La fin vient,
la fin vient,
elle se réveille contre toi,
voici elle vient. »
Il y a cette insistance
de Dieu.
Mais lorsque la fin
arrive pour les méchants,
comme indiqué
au verset 6,
alors c'est un mal absolu
dont ils ne vont
tirer aucune leçon.
La seule leçon
qu'ils vont en tirer,
c'est de reconnaître
que Dieu a été juste
dans ce qu'il avait annoncé.
Dieu ne punit pas
comme ça.
Dieu avertit.
Quand le jugement
de Dieu s'exerce,
personne ne pourra
dire un moment,
je n'ai pas vu
la miséricorde de Dieu
s'exercer avant
que je ne puisse
me repentir.
Les châtiments temporels,
même les plus cruels,
peuvent toujours
laisser une fenêtre
pour quelques allégements,
mais les tourments
qui arrivent
avec le jugement final
n'en auront pas.
Voilà pourquoi
nous sommes exhortés,
et là je peux aussi le dire,
c'est toujours important
de pouvoir prier
pour nos cœurs.
C'est une expérience
que je vis déjà
dans plusieurs années,
avec plusieurs années,
quand par exemple
nous avons une assemblée générale,
on va prononcer
un cas d'excommunication,
et souvent beaucoup,
une question récurrente
qui va toujours venir,
c'est de dire,
est-ce que vous avez
exercé suffisamment
de miséricorde
avant d'arriver à ça?
mais nous ne réalisons pas
un moment que quand Dieu permet
que nous arrivions
à ce point
de l'excommunication,
c'est que la patience
de Dieu est épuisée,
le péché est exposé,
et Dieu ne permet pas
que le péché
soit gardé
ou couvert
au sein de l'Église.
mais pour nous,
c'est de toujours réaliser
que viendra un temps
où il n'y aura plus de place
pour la repentance,
il viendra un temps
où la patience de Dieu
sera épuisée.
Le deuxième point,
le deuxième point,
donc ça,
c'était le premier point
qu'on peut voir
dans ce verset
qui résumait
ce que nous avions vu
la dernière fois,
mais qui voit un peu
avec ce point.
Le deuxième point
va venir maintenant
à partir du verset 7,
qui sera aussi
un peu la centralité
d'aujourd'hui.
Verset 7,
ton tour arrive,
habitant du pays,
le temps vient,
le jour approche,
jour de trouble,
et plus de cris de joie
dans les montagnes.
Ton tour arrive,
habitant du pays,
le temps vient,
le temps vient.
Dans tous les dessins
de Dieu,
il y a un temps convenable.
Dieu est le maître
des temps,
des circonstances.
Et là,
je reviens encore,
il y a des moments
où nous pouvons
tergiverser en tant qu'humains,
nous pouvons être choqués
lorsque le jugement
de Dieu arrive
dans l'Église
ou dans la nation,
mais la vérité est
qu'au temps fixé
par Dieu,
ce qu'il a décidé
s'accomplit.
Et c'est très important
lorsque nous sommes
en train de vivre
ces temps très difficiles
que nous sommes
en train de traverser,
s'intéressant
de revenir
sur ce passage
d'Ecclésiastes,
peut-être si vous ne l'avez
pas lu
depuis un moment
ou si vous le découvrez,
de pouvoir revenir
dans Ecclésiastes,
chapitre 3,
déjà au verset 11,
qu'est-ce qu'il va dire
en parlant de Dieu ?
Dieu,
il fait toutes choses
bonnes en son temps.
Même,
il a mis dans leur cœur
la pensée de l'éternité,
bien que l'homme
ne puisse pas saisir
l'œuvre que Dieu fait
du commencement
jusqu'à la fin.
Et voilà pourquoi
nous avons besoin
d'être humbles.
Lorsque Dieu
est en train
de nous enseigner,
lorsque nous sommes
en train de traverser
certains temps,
nous avons besoin
d'être humbles.
Nous avons besoin
que notre cœur
soit en train,
nous soyons en train
de dire,
Seigneur,
dispose au moins
un cœur pur.
Parce que nous
ne pouvons pas comprendre.
Déjà,
en tant qu'être humain,
lorsque nous jugeons
la situation
d'un autre être humain,
nous n'avons pas souvent
tout le tableau
et nous arrivons
à des conclusions.
Combien de fois
que nous sommes en train
de juger
ce que Dieu est en train
de faire ?
Ça, c'est de la pure folie.
Déjà,
quand nous le faisons
au niveau des êtres humains,
c'est de la pure folie.
Et quand nous parlons
de Dieu,
il n'y a même pas
de mots pour dire
ce que nous sommes
en train de faire.
Voilà ce que nous dit
Ecclésiastes,
chapitre 3,
du verset 1
au verset 8.
Il y a un temps
pour tout,
un temps pour toutes choses
sous les cieux,
un temps pour naître
et un temps pour mourir,
un temps pour planter
et un temps pour arracher
ce qui a été planté,
un temps pour tuer
et un temps pour guérir,
un temps pour abattre
et un temps pour bâtir,
un temps pour pleurer
et un temps pour rire,
un temps pour se lamenter
et un temps pour danser.
Il faudrait que les,
entre guillemets,
pasteurs de l'évangile
de prospérité
puissent revenir
et lire ce passage
de l'Ecclésiastes,
chapitre 3.
Ça permettrait de corriger
les hérésies
qui sont enseignées
au sujet de la prospérité
ou du triomphalisme.
Verset 5
un temps pour lancer
des pierres
et un temps pour ramasser
des pierres,
un temps pour embrasser
et un temps pour s'éloigner
des embrassements,
un temps pour chercher
et un temps pour perdre,
un temps pour garder
et un temps pour jeter,
un temps pour déchirer
et un temps pour coudre,
un temps pour se taire
et un temps pour parler,
un temps pour aimer
et un temps pour haïr,
un temps pour la guerre
et un temps pour la paix.
Ainsi,
quand Dieu permet
certains temps
et nous avons déjà pu vivre
des périodes dans notre vie
où ces temps-là nous arrivent,
il y a des temps
où nous allons pleurer
dans notre vie,
il y a des temps
où nous allons rire,
il y a d'autres temps
où nous allons chercher,
où nous allons perdre,
nous ne devrions pas
être surpris.
Quand nous connaissons
la parole de Dieu,
quand ces temps nous arrivent,
nous devrions être
en train de dire
Seigneur,
c'est quelque chose
de difficile
que je n'aimerais pas vivre
mais je prie
pour que ta volonté
soit faite
et je prie
pour que tu me soutiennes
pendant ces temps.
Le chrétien
ne doit pas être surpris
lorsque ces temps arrivent.
Celui qui ne connaît pas Dieu
va être surpris
puisque même un moment,
on va supposer un moment
que nous ne devons vivre
que dans un océan
de béatitude.
Quand vous regardez
même la vie des influenceurs,
on se dit un moment
que c'est le paradis
sur terre
tout au long de l'année.
Ce n'est pas le cas.
C'est un monde
qui est touché
par le péché
et même ces influenceurs
qui partagent une vie parfaite,
elle n'est pas parfaite derrière.
Ils pleurent,
ils sont sujets
à des pressions,
tout ce qu'ils sont en train
de faire à un coup.
Mais nous,
nous comprenons un moment
que ces temps
se manifesteront
et nous ne devons pas
être surpris.
Tout comme par rapport
à ces situations
que nous sommes en train de vivre,
ne serions pas surpris
par les guerres
et les bruits de guerre.
Toutes ces choses
doivent arriver
avant le retour
de notre Seigneur Jésus.
Bien sûr,
quand nous avons grandi
dans une paix relative
pendant plusieurs années,
certains sont nés ici,
ils n'ont pas connu
la chute du mur de Berlin.
Donc,
ils n'ont pas connu
la guerre froide
où à un moment
des bombes atomiques
pouvaient tomber
à n'importe quel moment
sur nos têtes.
Mais la réalité qu'il y a,
c'est que c'est un monde
qui est toujours dans le conflit,
c'est un monde
qui est toujours dans la guerre,
toujours.
Et même quand nous ne sommes pas
dans une guerre ouverte,
nous sommes dans une guerre
des personnalités,
dans la haine du prochain,
dans une société
de compétition.
mais nous,
nous avons la certitude
qu'un jour,
nous,
chrétiens,
nous avons la certitude
que le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
mettra fin
à tous les conflits,
il mettra fin
à toutes les peines,
à toutes les souffrances
de ce monde
et il consolera
les cœurs
de tous ceux
qui auront espéré
en lui jusqu'à la fin.
Nous devons prendre conscience
et voilà,
lorsque il est en train
de parler,
le temps vient,
ce temps,
ce temps va venir,
il y a un temps
pour la grâce de Dieu,
pour le jugement de Dieu.
Mais lorsque ces temps
sont en train d'arriver,
nous devons prendre conscience,
même si Israël
ne prenait pas conscience
que ce temps devait arriver,
l'enseignement
que nous,
nous avons,
que nous en ayons
conscience ou non,
le jour approche,
ce temps vient,
ce jour approche
où le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
rendra à chacun
selon ce qu'est son œuvre.
et bien que certains
vont le réduire
à un simple charpentier,
nous,
nous savons
qu'il est l'alpha
et l'oméga.
Nous savons
qu'il est le commencement
et la fin.
Nous savons
que pour nous
qui aurons lavé nos robes
avec le sang de l'agneau,
nous aurons droit
à l'arbre de vie
et nous entrerons
dans les portes
de la sainte ville.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose
que nous sommes,
nous avons chanté
Jérusalem tout à l'heure,
ce n'est pas quelque chose
de vain
que nous sommes en train
de chanter.
Nous sommes en train
de chanter une vérité
qui sera vécue
et qui doit nous donner
beaucoup d'espoir
quand nous sommes en train
de traverser
des moments difficiles,
même à l'horreur
d'une seconde,
de guerre,
de guerre violente.
Mais ce temps vient
où ceux,
Paul disait à un moment,
seront jetés dehors
les chiens.
Donc la Bible
souvent parle des chiens,
elle parle des personnes
qui ont une conduite horrible,
une conduite méprisable.
mais ce temps vient
où seront jetés dehors
les chiens,
les enchanteurs.
Il y a un temps
pour toutes choses,
mais ce temps viendra
où les chiens,
les enchanteurs,
les impudiques,
les meurtriers,
les idolâtres
et quiconque aura aimé
et pratiqué le mensonge
sera jeté
en dehors
de la présence de Dieu,
de la grâce de Dieu.
Le troisième aspect
qui nous parle aussi
de la patience
épuisée de Dieu,
nous le trouvons
toujours dans le verset 7,
quand il nous parle.
Donc tantôt arrive,
habitant du pays,
le temps vient,
le jour approche.
Le jour approche.
Ézéchiel leur a répété
à maintes reprises
que le jour
tant attendu
du jugement tomberait.
Vous voyez,
l'insistance,
tout à l'heure
quand notre frère Joachim
était en train de lire,
vous voyez l'insistance,
même si nous pouvons relire,
regardez comment c'est...
La parole de l'Éternel
me fut adressée
en ces mots.
Toi, fils de l'homme,
ainsi parle le Seigneur éternel
sur le pays d'Israël,
voici la fin.
Donc il nous dit déjà
Il reprend,
la fin vient
sous les quatre extrémités
du pays.
Maintenant,
la fin vient sur toi.
J'enverrai ma colère
contre toi,
je te jugerai
selon tes voies,
je te chargerai
de toutes tes abominations.
Mon œil sera pour toi
sans pitié
et je n'aurai
point de miséricorde.
Et là,
il reprend encore
ce qu'il avait déjà répété.
Mais je te chargerai
de tes voies
et tes abominations
seront au milieu de toi
et vous saurez
que je suis l'Éternel.
Et il reprend encore.
Ainsi parle
le Seigneur éternel,
un malheur,
un malheur unique,
voici,
il vient.
La fin vient.
On nous répète encore
la fin vient.
La fin vient,
elle se réveille
contre toi.
Voici,
elle vient.
La première fois
que j'ai lu ce passage,
je me suis dit,
je ne sais pas trop
comment je vais tirer
des enseignements de ça,
mais je vois le sens
de ce que Dieu voulait dire
maintenant.
Tantôt arrive,
habitant du pays,
le temps vient.
Le jour approche,
jour de troubles
et plus de cris de joie
dans les montagnes.
Maintenant,
je vais bientôt répandre
ma furent sur toi,
assouvir sur toi
ma colère.
Je te jugerai
selon tes voies,
alors qu'il l'a déjà
encore dit.
Il le répète,
je te chargerai
de toutes tes abominations.
Mon oeil sera sans pitié
et je n'aurai point
de miséricorde.
Je te chargerai
de tes voies
et tes abominations
seront au milieu de toi.
Et vous saurez
que je suis l'éternel,
celui qui frappe.
Voici le jour,
voici,
il vient.
Cette insistance
n'est pas faite
par hasard.
Qu'est-ce que Dieu
est en train
de nous enseigner ?
Il est en train
d'enseigner à Israël
quand il est en train
de leur parler ça.
Ézéchiel leur répète
à maintes reprises
que la fin vient,
que le jour approche,
car le jour
tant attendu
allait tomber.
Israël,
une chose
qui allait être palpable
parce que
si je t'ai dit
la fin vient une fois
et que tu as oublié après,
oui, c'est normal.
Mais si je t'ai répété
quinze fois
la fin vient,
si je te dis
à un moment
tu te souviens
de ce que je t'ai dit
et que tu me dis
non, je ne me souviens pas,
là c'est que tu es malhonnête.
Normalement,
tu vas te souvenir
que je te l'ai dit.
Et voilà,
Israël ne pouvait
donc pas avoir
d'excuses
de leur ignorance.
Israël ne pouvait
pas avoir une excuse
en disant à un moment
Dieu ne nous a pas donné
de la place
pour la repentance.
Dieu ne nous a pas
suffisamment avertis
avant que la fin n'arrive.
Non,
il y a eu plusieurs siècles
de patience de Dieu.
Et même après
les siècles de patience,
il y a eu plusieurs années
de patience de Dieu
juste avant le jugement.
La fin venait,
elle était de plus en plus
inéluctable,
mais Israël
a choisi de l'ignorer.
Mais une chose
qui était là,
c'est que Israël
ne pouvait pas dire
à un moment
je suis innocent
parce que mon Dieu
ne m'a pas suffisamment
averti.
Ce n'était pas possible.
de même
qu'Israël
a vécu ça,
aucun de nous,
de Adam
jusqu'à la génération
lorsque le Seigneur
Jésus-Christ reviendra,
aucune de notre génération
n'aura l'excuse
de l'ignorance
pour un avertissement
qui est donné
depuis l'aube
de l'humanité
et qui a été confirmé
par les jugements
ponctuels
que nous voyons,
que nous voyons
tout le temps.
Pourquoi il y a
ces jugements ?
Pourquoi Dieu juge
un moment quand le péché
arrive à un certain niveau
et que Dieu dit
un moment
je ne peux plus supporter,
je juge.
C'est parce qu'il est
en train de nous enseigner
par rapport au jugement final.
Il est en train
de nous enseigner
que le salaire du péché
c'est la mort.
Le salaire du péché
c'est la destruction.
Il est en train
de nous dire
tous ces jugements
temporaires
que vous avez vus
dans l'histoire d'Israël,
dans l'histoire
de l'humanité
à cause de l'idolâtrie
des peuples,
un jour
il y aura
un jugement final.
La fin vient.
Les jugements de Dieu
peuvent être différés
quand ils vont trouver
la patience de Dieu
sur leur chemin.
Ils peuvent être différés
lorsque en réponse
à cette patience
de Dieu
qui est exercée,
Dieu va trouver
des cœurs
qui s'humilient
et des cœurs
qui sont humbles.
Et voilà pourquoi
Dieu n'avait pas jugé
un moment.
Pendant plusieurs siècles,
Dieu a trouvé
des intercesseurs.
Ils n'étaient peut-être
pas nombreux,
ce n'était pas tout le peuple,
mais il y avait
des prêtres,
des prophètes,
des rois
qui se sont mis
à genoux
pour demander
pardon à Dieu
pour le peuple.
Et parce que Dieu
a trouvé leur repentance,
alors Dieu
n'a pas manifesté
son jugement.
Mais cela ne voulait pas dire
que les jugements
de Dieu
étaient abandonnés.
C'est ce que l'histoire
du peuple d'Israël
nous rappelle.
Dieu pardonne
le pécheur,
mais il ne peut pas laisser
ce que le péché a produit
sans jugement
de sa part
parce que sa sainteté
l'exige.
Et vous voyez,
je vous ai dit
un moment
quand nous avons lu
le passage,
qu'est-ce que Dieu dit
un moment
lorsqu'il exerce
ce jugement ?
Il va dire
enfin la terre d'Israël
va se reposer.
Un moment il dit
les commandements
que je vous avais donnés
de prendre soin
de la terre,
tous ces commandements
que vous deviez appliquer
vous ne les avez jamais appliqués
et cette terre
ne s'est jamais reposée.
Mais enfin
la terre d'Israël
va se reposer.
Et ce qu'il dit
un moment
pendant 70 ans
la terre d'Israël
connaîtra le repos
jusqu'à ce que
je vous ramène.
Donc Dieu
peut pardonner
mais Dieu ne laissera pas
que les conséquences
du péché
ne produisent pas
de jugement
de sa part.
Le péché
appelle
le jugement
de Dieu.
Mais
et voilà pourquoi
il va dire un moment
et ce qu'il dit
quand il parle
ainsi
du jour
qui approche
un des reproches
qui était fait
par Dieu
à Israël
nous est rappelé
au chapitre 14.
Donc si on va
dans Ézéchiel 14
du verset 1 à 2
quand il y a
quelques anciens
d'Israël
qui vont se présenter
devant Ézéchiel
voilà ce que Dieu dit
voilà ce que nous dit
la parole
quelques-uns des anciens
d'Israël
vinrent auprès
de moi
et s'assirent
devant moi
et la parole
de l'Éternel
me fut adressant
ces mots
fils de l'homme
ces gens-là
portent leurs idoles
dans leur cœur
et ils attachent
les regards
sur ce qui les a fait
tomber dans l'iniquité
me laisserai-je
consulter par eux
cette importance
du jour qui approche
c'est de parler
de ce contraste
entre la nuit
qui est profonde
c'est-à-dire
avant que le jour
n'approche
vous avez ce principe
de la nuit
qui est très profonde
et donc on va arriver
vers 1h du matin
2h du matin
jusqu'au moins
à 4h, 5h
vous avez ce principe
de la nuit profonde
et d'ailleurs
au niveau du sommeil
c'est là où nous allons
le plus dormir
c'est-à-dire
nous allons être
profondément endormis
et voilà
comment Dieu
était en train
de caractériser
Israël était
dans cette nuit avancée
dans cette nuit profonde
mais il y avait
le jour approché
où les choses
allaient être dévoilées
Israël avait agi
pendant plusieurs siècles
même encore là
quand il se présente
devant Ézéchiel
c'est-à-dire
à un moment
ils vont se dire
nous devons considérer
ce qu'Ézéchiel dit
mais nous ne voulons pas
obéir
à ce qu'il est en train
de nous recommander
Israël agissait
en confessant
une fidélité
à Dieu des lèvres
alors que le cœur
pensait autre chose
et c'est une chose
Dieu a toujours
fortement condamné
l'hypocrisie
et nous devons
toujours nous assurer
que ce que
nous sortons
de nos lèvres
soit bien
ce que nous pensons
de notre cœur
je me souviens
quand j'étais
plus jeune
j'avais peut-être
15 ans
je venais de me convertir
à l'église
quand les frères
chantaient
quand on chantait
fort en disant
je suis délivré
de l'amour du monde
je n'aime plus
les choses du monde
il y a un pasteur
qui nous a arrêté
un moment
il dit
si tu es en train
d'aimer le monde
et que tu es en train
de crier
très fort
je n'aime plus le monde
il faut te repentir
ce n'est pas honnête
que tu es en train
de chérir ces choses
et que tu es en train
de proclamer
de tes lèvres
un moment
que tu n'aimes plus
le monde
alors que
tout ton cœur
est entier là-dessus
nous devons veiller
à ne pas faire
ce qu'Israël
était en train de faire
Israël était en train
d'avoir cette facilité
d'affirmer
qu'ils aimaient Dieu
juste pour plaire
pour espérer
une clémence de Dieu
alors que leur cœur
n'était pas disposé
à aimer
et quand la Bible
nous parle
de cet aspect
du jour
qui approche
c'était cet aspect
à un moment
que cette hypocrisie
allait être mise à jour
là encore
examinant nos cœurs
faisons très attention
à un moment
c'est tellement facile
de parler à un moment
de dire des choses
même quand ces choses
ne sont pas en accord
avec ce que nous
portons dans notre cœur
parce que nous voulons
juste plaire
et même encore
au niveau de l'Église
on peut ne pas avoir
cette disposition
à aimer
comme notre Père Céleste
nous recommande
mais nous allons dire
un moment
nous allons avoir
cette facilité
un moment
à pouvoir manifester
de nos lèvres
que nous aimons
si tu ne peux pas
porter quelqu'un
dans ton cœur
ça peut arriver
déjà
après plusieurs années
d'entretien pastoraux
il y a des gens
qui ont été honnêtes
à un moment
en disant
je n'aime pas telle personne
si tu ne peux pas
porter quelqu'un
dans ton cœur
soit honnête
avec Dieu
si tu ne peux pas
faire telle ou telle chose
soit honnête
avec Dieu
mais ne reste pas
dans cet état
Dieu condamne
l'hypocrisie
à un moment
c'est de
pouvoir affirmer
une chose
alors que la réalité
n'est pas dans notre vie
si tu as du mal
à lire la Bible
quand des frères
te demandent
comment se porte
ta lecture
ne dis pas
juste
oh ça va
juste pour dire
ça va
sois honnête
et dis
ça ne va pas
et pointe
ce qui va
parce que
le but n'est pas
de rester dans cet état
mais c'est de voir
qu'est-ce que tu as
à corriger
pour pouvoir lire
la parole
lorsque tu as affaire
à l'hypocrisie
sois honnête
vis-à-vis de Dieu
en disant
par rapport
à cette situation
mon coeur pense ça
mais mes lèvres
disent autre chose
Seigneur pardonne-moi
et que je puisse
m'aligner
que mon coeur
puisse s'aligner
avec
pas juste
pour faire plaisir
aux gens
Dieu allait exposer
ce que Israël
portait réellement
dans leur coeur
c'était ce sens aussi
du jugement
les preuves
avaient exposé
ce en quoi
ils mettaient
leur confiance
parce que vous voyez
ce qui se passe
à un moment
c'est que
on le voit
à Jérusalem
c'est que
quand Jérémie
les avertit
que Babylone
va arriver
ils ne croient pas
mais Babylone
arrive
et d'ailleurs
je vous avais dit
à un moment
que le seul
le seul
qui a été autorisé
à aller
où il voulait
quand les babyloniens
ont pris le pays
c'était Jérémie
ils lui ont dit
nous savons
ce que tu annonces
depuis
tu avais annoncé
que notre roi
allait venir
prendre Jérusalem
toi tu es libre
d'aller où tu veux
c'était le seul
et donc
quand Jérémie
leur annonce
et qu'ils voient
que Nebuchadnezzar arrive
à un moment
ils vont se repentir
mais
dès qu'ils voient
à un moment
que Nebuchadnezzar
est tiré
par l'Egypte
ils repartent
dans leurs idolâtries
ils se remettent
à maltraiter Jérémie
et les autres prophètes
ils révélaient
ce qu'ils portaient
dans leur coeur
Dieu était un Dieu
utilitaire pour eux
qui leur permettait
juste d'arriver
à leur fin
ou bien de se sentir
en paix dans leur coeur
mais Dieu allait exposer
en refusant d'écouter
les prophètes
qui les appelaient
à la repentance
Dieu allait maintenant
réellement exposer
ce qu'il y avait
dans leur coeur
et voilà pourquoi
la Bible nous parle
du jour qui approche
quand le jour approche
d'ailleurs
quand on dit souvent
généralement
même les horaires
dont je vous ai parlé
ce sont les horaires
où les voleurs
opèrent le plus
le voleur n'opère pas
à 23h
1h du matin
pour venir voler chez toi
c'est quand on est
entre 1h
et 4h du matin
quand la nuit
est avancée
c'est là où le voleur
aussi opère
mais quand on arrive
à 4h-5h du matin
le voleur disparaît
pourquoi ?
parce que le jour approche
et pourquoi
il disparaît
c'est parce que
ses oeuvres
vont être exposées
et là encore
en Afrique
à un moment
on a eu
des voleurs
qui
dans la nuit
en se cherchant
à fuir
il a été coincé
dans la fenêtre
pour fuir
il n'arrivait plus
à sortir
et le matin
les propriétaires
le trouvent
coincé
les propriétaires
le trouvent
coincé
dans le
le tuyau
d'évacuation
il n'arrive plus
à sortir
parce que
le jour approche
et là on voit
les oeuvres
mais vous voyez
ce qui est important
et comment nous voyons
l'unité de la parole
de Dieu
nous voyons
comment la Bible
nous dévoile
ce fil rouge
cet aspect
de cette nuit
qui est avancée
et d'être vigilant
parce que la nuit
avancée
est en train
de caractériser
la manifestation
des oeuvres
des ténèbres
mais qu'un jour
le jour approche
et quand le jour approche
on nous parle
ça peut être
du jugement temporaire
de Dieu
comme ça a été le cas
sur Israël
mais ça peut être
aussi le jugement
final qui arrive
voilà ce que Paul
est en train
de nous dire
et ça peut rejoindre
ce que nous venons
de lire
avec le verset 7
de Ézéchiel
voici ce que Paul
nous dit un moment
cela importe
d'autant plus
je crois
c'est Ephésiens 5
verset 11
non
je ne vais pas
la référence
oui oui
Romain 13
merci
cela importe
d'autant plus
que vous savez
en quel temps
nous sommes
c'est l'heure
de vous réveiller
en fin du sommeil
car maintenant
le salut
est plus près de nous
que lorsque
nous avons cru
la nuit est avancée
donc la même
rhétorique
que nous trouvons
dans Ézéchiel
la nuit est avancée
le jour approche
le jugement arrive
dépouillons-nous
donc des œuvres
des ténèbres
et revêtons
les armes
de la lumière
le chrétien
il est très important
pour le chrétien
de savoir
distinguer
les temps
il est très important
pour le chrétien
de ne pas
être endormi
à cause
de l'amour du monde
et des soucis
qui accompagnent
l'amour du monde
parce que
ces soucis
cet amour du monde
et les soucis
qui l'accompagnent
vont refroidir
notre amour
pour Dieu
vont nous avachir
nous rendre mous
nous devons prendre conscience
même si
vous voyez
Israël ne voyait pas
les signes du jugement
à un moment
eux ils voyaient
qu'il n'y avait pas
de jugement qui arrive
il y a des gens
qui ne voient pas
que le jugement arrive
mais nous
nous devons être conscients
que nous nous approchons
chaque jour qui passe
nous nous rapprochons
encore plus
du retour du sien à Jésus
la nuit est avancée
mais le jour
approche
lorsque le jugement
de Dieu s'exerce
même le péché caché
au plus profond
d'un coeur
est exposé
la Bible nous rappelle
à un moment
que tout ce qui est condamné
est manifesté
par la lumière
car tout ce qui est
manifesté
est lumière
et le sien Jésus
se rappelait à un moment
qu'il n'y a rien de caché
qui ne doit être découvert
ni de secret
qui ne doit être connu
l'homme agit
à un moment
en pensant à un moment
qu'il aura suffisamment
de force
pour cacher son péché
pour refuser
de se repentir
ne fuyons pas
la lumière
quand Dieu expose
ce que peut porter
notre coeur
ayons l'humilité
à un moment
d'être honnête
parce que
fuir la lumière
que signifie
selon la parole de Dieu
c'est quand on refuse
d'abandonner un péché
de se repentir
ça c'est une caractéristique
de fuir la lumière
le non-croyant
fuir la lumière
parce qu'il ne veut pas
que ses oeuvres
soient exposées
et il veut pouvoir
continuer à pécher
librement
mais le chrétien
lorsque le jour
approche
lorsque la lumière
de Dieu arrive
et même
qu'un jugement
temporaire
peut s'exercer
dans notre vie
parce que
le péché
a des conséquences
quand nous péchons
un moment
nous pouvons avoir
des conséquences
quand je vais mentir
mon mensonge
va avoir des conséquences
parce que souvent
le problème
c'est que nous espérons
que notre péché
bien sûr
Dieu ne nous juge
pas à la hauteur
de ce que nous méritons
mais tout péché
que nous commettons
a des conséquences
et nous devons prier
un moment
pour que la miséricorde
de Dieu
atténue ses conséquences
mais Dieu n'enlève
pas les conséquences
et donc
nous devons prier
un moment
que lorsque notre péché
termine à la lumière
par Dieu
nous ne soyons pas
en train de faire
comme Adam et Ève
qui sont allés se cacher
mais que nous soyons
en train de dire
Seigneur
tu vois ce que porte
mon cœur
je te prie
de me pardonner
et je te prie
de m'aider
à grandir
dans cette repentance
un professeur
de mathématiques
irlandais
John Lennox
vous pouvez voir ça
souvent
sur les réseaux sociaux
il a dit
il a un moment
certains disent
que la religion
est une histoire
pour enfants
destinée aux gens
qui ont peur du noir
je dis
que l'athéisme
est une histoire
pour enfants
destinée aux gens
qui ont peur
de la lumière
n'ayant pas peur
et
le dernier point
que nous allons voir
aujourd'hui
dans cette patience
de Dieu à sa limite
le dernier point
se trouve
toujours dans le verset 7
tantôt arrive
habitant du pays
le temps vient
le jour approche
jour de trouble
en répétant
que la fin
était certaine
donc nous avons lu
ce passage
où Dieu dit
le temps vient
la fin est certaine
en répétant
que la fin est certaine
que le temps
du jugement
arrivait
et que la longue nuit
qui avait vu
les péchés d'Israël
donc depuis ce temps
où Israël se livre
à l'idolâtrie
pendant plusieurs siècles
sans que Dieu
n'exerce un jugement
final
la Bible nous considère
c'est un peu comme
cette longue nuit
pendant cette longue nuit
qui avait vu
les péchés d'Israël
cette longue nuit
était en train
d'arriver à son terme
Dieu allait juger Israël
le jour de justice
allait arriver
et quand Dieu parle
d'un jour de trouble
c'est que sa décision
était arrêtée
qu'est-ce que c'est
le trouble
c'est
quand on est dans
la confusion
le trouble
qu'est-ce que
le trouble produit
on n'a pas de paix
quand on est troublé
on est dans la confusion
nous n'avons pas de paix
on manque de repères
et voilà
ce que Dieu
est en train de dire
de ce qui allait
arriver à Israël
Israël allait être
dans la confusion
dans le manque de paix
Israël allait perdre
tous ses repères
tout cela serait
leur partage
avec ce jugement
voilà pourquoi
la Bible nous parle
d'un jour de trouble
un jour
où la patience
de Dieu
est arrivée
à sa limite
et
sur la conclusion
que je peux porter
c'est très important
pour nous
voilà encore
ce que le Seigneur
Jésus-Christ dit
dans Matthieu
Matthieu 24
et
j'ai trouvé
un moment
en préparant le message
j'ai trouvé aussi
que c'était une très bonne
exhortation
pour nous rappeler
à cette espérance
que nous portons
et
au contraire
de celui
qui ne connait pas Dieu
qui va être
dans la confusion
dans le manque de paix
dans le trouble
voilà ce que nous dit
la parole
Matthieu 24
à partir du verset 6
vous entendrez
parler de guerre
et de bruit de guerre
gardez-vous
d'être troublés
d'avoir de la confusion
d'avoir un manque
de paix
de repères
le chrétien
ne peut pas être
dans cet état
vous entendez
parler de guerre
de bruit de guerre
gardez-vous
d'être troublés
car il faut
que ces choses arrivent
mais ce ne sera
pas encore la fin
une nation
s'élèvera
contre une nation
et un royaume
contre un royaume
et il y aura
en divers lieux
des famines
et des tremblements
de terre
tout cela
ne sera
que le commencement
des douleurs
alors on vous livrera
en tourment
et l'on vous fera
mourir
et vous serez
haïs de toutes les nations
à cause de mon nom
alors aussi
plusieurs succomberont
et se trahiront
se haïront
les uns les autres
plusieurs faux prophètes
s'élèveront
et ils séduiront
beaucoup de gens
parce que l'iniquité
se sera accrue
la charité du plus grand nombre
se refroidira
mais celui
qui persévérera
jusqu'à la fin
sera sauvé
cette bonne nouvelle
du royaume
sera prêchée
dans le monde entier
pour servir de témoignage
à toutes les nations
alors viendra la fin
face à un monde
qui est troublé
qui manque de paix
face à un monde
qui vit
un jour
de trouble temporaire
avant le jour
de trouble final
face à un monde
qui n'a pas de repère
voici ce que la parole
de Dieu nous dit
à un moment
cette espérance
que le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
nous dit à un moment
de ne pas être inquiet
de ne pas être troublé
et ce qui est même drôle
c'est que quand Dieu
va nous recommander
de prier
la première chose
pour laquelle
Dieu nous recommande
de prier
ce n'est pas de prier
en disant
Seigneur mon cœur est troublé
apporte de la paix
ce n'est pas ça
qu'est-ce que Dieu nous dit
quels que soient les temps
que nous sommes en train
de traverser
nous avons lu
Ecclesiastes chapitre 3
c'est temps pour toute chose
il y a un temps
ou un moment
on aurait voulu
avoir un enfant
on va avoir une fausse couche
il y a un temps
où on aurait voulu
avoir un emploi
on n'aura pas d'emploi
il y a un temps
où on va être touché
par le deuil
il y a un temps
où on va être touché
par la maladie
il y a un temps
de joie
il y a toutes ces choses là
mais qu'est-ce que la Bible
nous dit à un moment
en priant
ne multipliez pas
de vaines paroles
comme les païens
qui s'imaginent
qu'à force de parole
ils seront exaucés
ne leur ressemblez pas
car votre père
sait de quoi
vous avez besoin
avant que vous
le lui demandiez
voici donc
comment vous devez prier
est-ce que
c'est de prier un moment
en disant
Seigneur
ramène la paix
il ne faut pas
qu'il y ait une troisième
guerre mondiale
avant que j'ai passé
mon permis
avant que je me sois marié
avant que j'ai vécu
telle ou telle chose
est-ce que c'est ça
la prière
que Dieu nous demande
de faire
non
notre père
qui es aux cieux
que ton nom
soit sanctifié
le plus important
pour nous
c'est de considérer
quand nous traversons
tous ces temps
dont je vous ai parlé
parce que même
un temps de joie
peut être une occasion
de chute
pour le croyant
le temps de joie
peut me conduire
à me détacher
de Dieu
parce que je m'estime
béni
à un moment
je m'estime
ne plus avoir besoin
de la grâce de Dieu
ne plus dépendre
mais voilà
comment nous devons prier
quels que soient
les temps
les circonstances
que nous traversons
que ton nom
soit sanctifié
que le nom de Dieu
dans ma vie
le nom de Dieu
soit sanctifié
dans mon être
dans les motifs
que je porte
dans les pensées
dans les paroles
dans les actes
je vois les troubles
je vois les bruits
de guerre
je vois les inquiétudes
du monde
qu'est-ce que Dieu
me dit de faire
que son nom
soit sanctifié
dans ma vie
qu'est-ce que Dieu
me dit de faire
que son règne vienne
le chrétien
doit être en train
de soupirer
lorsqu'il a affaire
un monde
de méchanceté
et qu'il voit
toute cette méchanceté
il ne doit pas juste
être en train de dire
j'espère que l'ONU
va faire quelque chose
j'espère que tel président
va faire ça
que tel homme
le chrétien doit dire
Seigneur Jésus revient
le chrétien doit être
en train de soupirer
pour que le Seigneur
revienne
voilà comment nous devons
prier
que le nom de Dieu
soit sanctifié
dans nos vies
que son règne vienne
que sa volonté
soit faite
sur la terre
comme au ciel
nous aimerions
tellement un moment
que Dieu
puisse s'aligner
sur ce que nous portons
sur la vision
que nous voulons avoir
de notre vie
mais pourtant
ce n'est pas ce qui se passe
là peut-être même
depuis que l'année
a commencé
il y a beaucoup de choses
que tu n'aurais pas
voulu vivre
mais tu les as vécues
mais qu'est-ce que Dieu
nous enseigne là-dessus
Père
que ta volonté
soit faite
les choses ne se passeront
peut-être pas
comme je l'ai désiré
mais que ta volonté
soit faite
pour que lorsque
je suis en train
de vivre ces choses
que je puisse être béni
que je puisse être
en train de saisir
ce que tu es en train
de m'apprendre
lorsque ces temps
ces bruits de guerre
lorsque ces bruits de guerre
sont en train
de nous envahir
que ta volonté
soit faite
Donne-nous aujourd'hui
notre pain quotidien
parce que chaque jour
nous devons apprendre
de cette dépendance
à Dieu
nous ne devons pas
être en train
de demander
le pain quotidien
lorsque le prix
de l'essence
a grimpé
et que c'est là
on se dit
il va falloir que je prie
parce que sinon
j'aurais du mal
à acheter ma baguette
mais nous devons réaliser
notre besoin
de dépendance à Dieu
pour que nous ne soyons
pas dans le jour
de trouble
lorsque le jour
de trouble arrive
pour que nous ne soyons
pas en train
de manquer de paix
que nous ne soyons
pas en train
de manquer de repères
nous devons être
en train de dépendre
de la grâce de Dieu
nous devons être
en train de dépendre
de la grâce de Dieu
certaines choses
vont nous arriver
que nous n'aurions pas voulu
mais parce que je dépends
de la grâce de Dieu
je sais que Dieu
prendra soin de moi
pardonne-nous nos offenses
comme nous aussi
nous pardonnons
à ceux qui nous ont offensés
je vous ai dit
à un moment
que lorsque le jour
de trouble arrive
lorsque le jugement
de Dieu s'exerce
les cœurs sont dévoilés
et souvent nous voyons
qu'il y a des choses
dont nous n'allons pas
être fiers
à un moment
les gens vont se battre
pour telle chose
les gens vont trahir
leurs voisins
il y a beaucoup de choses
horribles
que des simples citoyens
des simples personnes
vont faire
parce que le jour
de trouble est là
mais qu'est-ce que
la Bible nous dit
à un moment
nous devons avoir
cette disposition
même quand nous sommes
en train de vivre
la méchanceté des hommes
dans les jours de trouble
nous devons être en train
de pardonner
comme Dieu nous a pardonné
nous devons être en train
de prier
pour que Dieu garde
notre cœur
de la tentation
parce que le jour de trouble
aligne ce que nous pensons
dans le cœur
et l'une des premières choses
souvent
et où nous avons besoin
de corriger notre cœur
c'est parce que ce sentiment
d'hostilité vers Dieu
va toujours être naturel
parce que nous sommes encore
dans un corps
qui est touché par le péché
en attendant
une pleine délivrance
et la première préoccupation
à un moment
c'est de reprocher à Dieu
ce que nous sommes
en train de vivre
c'est de reprocher à Dieu
ce que nous sommes
en train de voir
autour de nous
mais pourquoi Dieu
est en train de permettre ça
pourquoi Dieu
mais qu'est-ce que
la Bible nous dit
ne nous induit pas
en tentation
que nous ne soyons pas
en train d'avoir
un cœur qui soit hostile
à Dieu
mais que nous soyons
en train d'avoir
un cœur qui dépend de Dieu
un cœur qui est en train
de dire Seigneur
face à telle situation
ne laisse pas mon cœur
en train d'aller loin de toi
même face à une situation
de prospérité
ne laisse pas mon cœur
aller loin de toi
mais délivre-moi du malin
parce que je n'ignore pas
les plans de Satan
c'est que
quand je traverse les temps
au lieu que je sache
analyser les temps
les plans de Satan
c'est d'apporter la confusion
c'est de confondre les temps
c'est d'exiger
certaines choses à Dieu
lorsque je suis en train
de traverser certains temps
mais je dois comprendre
le moment que
quand je traverse un temps
Dieu l'a voulu
dans sa souveraineté
ce n'est pas facile
mais je dois faire
confiance à Dieu
et la conclusion
de la prière
car c'est à toi
qu'appartiennent
pas seulement
dans notre
peut-être
il y en a
qui ont traversé
un quart de siècle
un demi-siècle
non
car c'est à toi
qu'appartiennent
dans tous les siècles
depuis
toute la temporalité
de la présence
de Adam
jusqu'à nous
et même avant
car c'est à toi
qu'appartiennent
dans tous les siècles
le règne
la puissance
et la gloire
même quand les hommes
ont l'impression
que Dieu ne règne pas
même quand les hommes
ont l'impression
que Dieu n'est pas puissant
que Dieu n'est pas glorieux
dans ce qu'il est en train
de manifester
la parole de Dieu
nous dit
que Dieu
est celui à qui appartiennent
dans tous les siècles
le règne
la puissance
et la gloire
Amen